hey how's it going bros my name is today
we're going to play one of the most
requested games of all time for me at
least on this channel undertale if
you're seeing this right now all the
other episodes will be up if you check
out the playlist down below it'll be my
little gift to you so you can binge
watch the whole game right now right as
this is out I have played probably the
first it says 25 minutes but I haven't
played that long I promise I probably
play like five minutes
long ago two races rule over the Earth
humans and monsters or months tea one
day war broke out between the two races
after a long battle
the humans were victorious well that's
good I don't I don't like Monsters
winning they seal the monsters
underground with a magic spell
many years later
mount a butt
thousand and
10x Legends say that those who climb the
mountain never return
I like the music it's very nice so far
okay well someone's going into the
mountain obviously
and I'm guessing I'm gonna fall down
seems a bit like a Alice in the
Wonderland
which was written in Brighton where I am
right now fun fact but no one gives a
[ __ ] about
I've already heard a lot of the
soundtrack outside of playing the game
and it's really good
I really like the minimalist
minimalistic approach to the game
undertale here we go
press two or enter I'll press two
because that's [ __ ] weird
did I Tab out
okay well let's press enter
um control shift
cancel XZ to confirm when HP is zero you
lose
I hope I can save
this game is made by Toby Fox
and I just quit the [ __ ] game
oh man what a [ __ ] train wreck
oh okay we're back I didn't take that
long
um Fallen human show me Felix or pants
I'll be
Pewds yes
all right all right all right
and this is us I wonder what the real
name of the main character is maybe it
doesn't have one
the face looks like that uh uh I don't
know how to explain it never mind
all right let's go in here oh a cute
little flower howdy I'm flowey flowey
the flower
what a wonderful name
I think we'll be best friends
hmm
you're new to the underground aren't you
golly you must be so confused someone
how to teach you how things work around
here
I guess little old meal will have to do
ready here we go
see that heart that is your soul the
very culminating of your being
all right and I can move it around
your soul starts off weak but you can
grow strong if you gain a lot of level
or LV
what's what's LV stand for why love of
course
you want some love don't you
I can't say no to that
don't worry I'll share some with you
oh thanks
down here love is shared through little
white friendliness Palace
are you ready question mark move around
get as many as you can so I know that
these are bad because I play the first
five minutes I wonder what happens if I
miss them hey buddy you missed them
let's try again okay
what happens if I dodge them
he's getting pissed off already this is
a joke are you brain Red Dead run into
the bullets oh the bullets you mean the
friendliness pellets wow what a deep
detail game already oh God you know
what's going on here don't you
yes
I'll tell you where where I got to in
the in the playthrough
you just wanted to see me suffer oh my
God die
Jesus Christ that's [ __ ] terrifying
uh oh
what is that
what a terrible creature torturing such
a poor innocent youth huh don't be
afraid my child
I'm toriel
caretaker of the ruins
I passed through this place every day to
see if anyone has fallen down
you are the first human to come here in
a long time come I will guide you
through the catacombs
this way there's a lot of reading in the
sky I'll go this way
so I know that there's different types
of runs you can do in this game uh the
infamous genocide run where you can kill
everyone We're not gonna kill everyone I
think for the first playthrough
we'll keep it nice and easy
well it depends I'll see what I feel
like the shadow of the ruins looms above
filling you with determination HP fully
restored and now I can save thank you
it's beautiful it reminds me of a just
good old RPG Maker game
I don't think it's made in RPG Maker
though welcome to your new home innocent
one allow me to educate you in the
operations of the ruins
the ruins are full Apostles ancient
fusions between diversions and dorkies
when we saw them she moved from room to
room please adjust yourself to the site
of them
what do you want me to do what does that
mean what is this
Only The Fearless May proceed brave ones
foolish ones both walk not the Middle
Road
okay to make progress here you will need
to trigger several switches do not worry
I have labeled the ones that you need to
flip well that's easy enough
stay on the path well I'm sorry
Jesus Christ
this is cool so far I'm really enjoying
it
I like my face I'm so
that that just looks like a meme I don't
even know
okay well that looks bad go on press the
switch on the left
I guess
that should be her right shouldn't it
Splendid I'm proud of you little one
let's move to the next room
oh they even marked over the [ __ ]
Arrow I wonder what happens if I do the
opposite oh man
I can tell you you can replay this game
uh as a human living in the underground
mantis Monsters May attack you you will
need to be prepared for this situation
however very not the process is simple
when you encounter a monster you will
enter a fight while you're in a fight
strike up a friendly conversation stall
for time I will come to resolve the
conflict
practice talking to the dummy
practice talking to a dummy with
you encounter the dummy
okay so I'll do an act
and I'll talk you talk to the dummy it
doesn't seem much for conversation
well what do you know
toriel's seems happy with you you won
you earned zero XP and zero gold
best fight ever wow
ah very good you are very good
thanks
there's another puzzle in the shirt I
wonder if you can solve it I have a
feeling I can
if they're all equally hard as this one
oh [ __ ] what happened frogging anyone
but frog it
what is going on down there
okay let's do uh let's let's uh
let's check frogging yes attack four
defense five life is difficult for this
enemy oh
poor thing what
well what a battle oh boy
the Western room is the Eastern's room's
blueprint okay
here we go
this is the puzzle but here take my hand
for a moment
okay do I need to remember this
I hope not
oh God I already forgot it
I like my sweater
puzzles seem a little too dangerous for
now
why is this woman so nice or thing I
guess cow thing
you have done excellently thus far my
child however I have a difficult request
to ask of you
I would like you to walk to the end of
the room by yourself
forgive me for this
mommy mommy
son don't leave me mommy said
you know you know shit's real when you
have music like this going
I like my walking animation too
it's time to walk in real life is this
all I have to do I just wanted to walk
by the end of the room are you kidding
me
I haven't played this far by the way
uh so I don't know what happened Beyond
this point oh
critics for my child
do not worry I did not leave you I was
merely behind this pillar though
thank you for trusting me however that
was an important reason for this
exercise to test your Independence
okay I must attend to some business and
you must stay alone for a while please
remain here it's dangerous to explore by
yourself I have an idea I will give you
a cell phone
what if you had need for anything just
call be good all right
I just call
okay well I guess I'll call mommy son on
my cell phone you used to call me on my
why can I
periods level one
zero in everything
I have a stick and a bandage as armor
all right so here's my cell phone say
hello about yourself call Mom
dialing
this is toriel
bass Mom did you just call me Mom well I
suppose
would that make you happy to call me
mother
well then call me whatever you like
click
what what is this game
I'm gonna go forward
hello this is toriel you have not left
the room have you there are a few
puzzles ahead that I have yet to explain
it would be dangerous to try and sell
them by yourself be good alright
click all right we're gonna sell them by
ourselves let's do a save here
filthy with determination
all right doing good let's talk to
Bullfrog get it excuse me human
I have some advice for you about
battling monsters if you act a certain
way or fight until you almost defeat
them they might not want to battle you
anymore if a monster does want to fight
you please use some mercy human ribbon
oh there we go our first first fight for
ourselves oh boy am I excited
um
what is it a weekly
let's check it
this monster is too sensitive to fight
so let forgive me
oh he's sad about attacking us
wimson continues to moderate apologies
should we be mean to him and maybe he'll
leave us alone
or maybe console that would make more
sense actually halfway through your
first word whims and burst into tears
and runs away
wimson no no XP how do I get XP I need
to level up man
ah
all right I'm going south I don't know
if this is oh boy no I'm going to sound
far right
let's go back up again
all right what about here no that's
another hole
well I suppose I can just walk up this
way
there we go oh another fight it's very
pokemonish frog it hopped close
okay what's up with frog it then
life is difficult oh yeah we knew that
oh God this is gonna yeah
it doesn't seem to know why it's here
well I can relate to that how about we
threaten him
he didn't understand what you said but
was scared anyway
and he's shivering I'm sorry froggit man
um
how about we threatening him again
shiver shiver
okay I don't really under seem to
reluctant to fight you
could I just fight him I don't hop hop
oh okay we'll actually fight this one I
am not sure how it works I'm sorry if
you I bet a lot of people who's like I
already [ __ ] know everything about
this game
Crow crook oh God that almost hit me
[ __ ]
he's trying to run away
then let's show Mercy
you won
one gold
so
I guess we don't have to kill anything
tutorial for no reason in particular
which do you prefer cinnamon or
butterscotch cinnamon what about you
leave a comment I would like to know
very much oh I see thank you very much
typical mom conversation to just call
out of nowhere and ask hello this is oh
my god do you not dislike a butterscotch
do you I know what your preference is
but
would you turn up your nose if you found
it on your plate right right I
understand thank you for being patient
by the way
what Mom base mom please three out of
four gray rocks recommend you push them
okay well
another fight
oh no not wimson all right we'll we'll
just uh console wimson
poor wimson
okay we saw the puzzle
I suppose we can keep going
um
oh [ __ ] sake
oh okay
please don't step on the leaves I think
I got it
so the rooms are um oh [ __ ] sake the
mirrored what is this a mold small
let's check it
curvaceously attractive but no brains I
wouldn't really call that attractive but
maybe maybe that's just good old me you
know what I'm saying
very interesting gameplay uh verbals
quietly all right well
I don't think it will understand if we
talk to it so I'm just gonna attack it
scourge
so I guess you want to be careful how
much you wait expensively how much you
damage it so now I'll go for yellow
Scorch and then we'll make a run away
we're not killing anything
Mercy
two gold I'll take the gold
all right here we go oh God I don't know
if I remembered it was like
it's like this
I think
no
no ah come on man
[ __ ] man ah [ __ ] man frogging hop close
how do you how do we deal with froggit
again do we attack him yeah
sorry froggit I love you man
it's like my Dr crab
we're not killing anyone here okay
how do you use that attack I don't
understand
can I murder see them right away maybe
I feel like I'm doing something wrong
and that people are gonna be pissed but
[ __ ] you all right be as pissed as you
want I'm playing the oh God
okay I think you you're Justified to be
pissed about that one that was kind of
embarrassing please edit that out future
Pips but [ __ ]
let's check actually
oh okay you can just spare them right
away
do I need to level up am I going to be
in trouble if I don't level up
we're just gonna have to find out
here we go let's push some some
Jennifer's thank you Peach
um you're welcome oh God a pair of frogs
I can't Mercy them right away
what do I do then
I'll fight frog at a bam
okay double attacks
[ __ ] you frog
and then we'll attack you
rip it Ribbit hop hop
oh God
uh no we still can't seem to
oh God please don't die meow what
I don't think I ever heard a cow yeah no
that made sense
it's trying to run away
and do it
do it [ __ ] no no no
foggy
I'm sorry Mercy Mercy well his friend
lived
I have no idea if that will have any
impact whatsoever but I'm so whoa there
partner
you who said you could push me around
Jennifer
so you're asking me to move over okay
just for you pumpkin
hmm you want me to move some more
alrighty how's this now Jennifer
foreign that was the wrong direction
okay I think I got it
thank you Jennifer you're the best
Jennifer
you wanted me to stay over there
they're giving me a real workout how is
it working if you just stayed Jennifer
don't pull any [ __ ] Jennifer
[ __ ] oh save save station gotta love
my save station
it fills you with determination let's do
another save is that a mouse hole here
okay we gotta get the mouse out this
cheese has been here for quite a long
time it's stuck to the table that's
disgusting
what the [ __ ] is this
oh are they gone yet
the ghosts keep saying Zed online
repeatedly pretending to sleep move it
with Force yes or no yes oh God
oh
funky
yes I like it nap stab look NAB stab
look sounds like Hoobastank you bros
remember that old band no all right cool
let's uh check it oh I can flirt
attack 10 defense ten this monster
doesn't seem to have a sense of humor oh
I'm real funny
oh God he's crying
he's salty salty tears
NAB stab look is wishing they weren't
here
all right I'm sure we can make him move
out of one away there
threat
I'll give him a cruel look go ahead do
it
really not filling up to it right now
sorry
what does that mean
oh God no [ __ ]
it sorry I [ __ ] up
are those [ __ ] Mac is it crying
maggots
oh God that's hard to dodge
all right we'll find him
just plugging along
oh god he has a lot of help is this like
a boss or some [ __ ]
oh God I sucked
hit him right between the eye
is there a trick to these because I feel
like I don't know it
I'm gonna die if I [ __ ] God
people die if they get killed
come on give me the no not those I don't
know how to
it's really hard to [ __ ] Dodge I
can't [ __ ] go anywhere
I'm fine thanks
oh there we go I can I can only Dodge
the [ __ ] tears
he's wishing they weren't here
all right one more hit
am I supposed to kill him I don't wanna
this is not what we're doing we're not
killing God damn it
pretendously
oh God I can't spare him I think I might
die here
one more hit
uh you do know you can't kill ghosts
right
we're sort of incorporal and all I was
just lowering my HP because I didn't
want to
sorry I just
I just [ __ ] awkward
this is super awkward
pretend you beat me
hey I lost an experience Point what is
this game I don't understand can we go
up here
oh
okay let's go here
did you miss it spider big sailed down
and to write come eat food made by
spiders for spiders off spiders well boy
I can't miss on that one I bet I better
I better get going again check that out
[ __ ] out spider bake sale all proceeds
go to real spiders that's nice
I appreciate that uh leave 17 7 G's
yes
some spiders crawl down and give you a
donut
thanks spiders
you didn't have enough gold well I have
a donut now that's never not a good
thing
I don't know what the [ __ ] that means am
I the only one who thinks that's the
spider the Frog's balls dangling down
there I can't be the only one rabbit
ribbon
Sai my friend never listens to me
whenever I talk they skip through my
words by pressing X I don't know I could
do that
that's right pressing X
oh no not YouTube
that's a fun way to
tutorial or something rabbit Ribbit I
heard using F4 can make you go full
screen
but what does F4 stand for four frogs
probably most likely yes I've only seen
a maximum of three frogs in this room
it's troubling to say the least rabbit
rabbit that is actually kind of
terrifying Ribbit I heard you are quite
the merciful quite merciful for a human
surely you know by now I'm a monster's
monster where a yellow name when you can
spare it oh I know by that
what do you think of that uh it's bad
very helpful it is rather helpful
remember sparing is just saying you
won't fight maybe one day you'll have to
do it even if their name isn't jello
oh God it's based mom again hello
I just realized that it's been a while
since I've cleaned up I was not
expecting to have company so soon
there are probably a lot of things lying
around here and there you can pick them
up but do not carry more than you need
someday you you might see something you
really like you will want to leave room
in your pockets for that
oh really so maybe picking up a donut
wasn't the best thing after all
interesting
there's just one switch
can I go inside these no I can't
what is this
oh all right well I picked the wrong one
oh it's
this one oh God
oh [ __ ] I need help
flee
okay good I can flee
I need another checkpoint
was that it
yay I am a genius
genius pill distraction it's a switch
press it of course nothing happened
awesome
it's a switch present yes nothing
happened but if I don't press it
nothing happens
it's a switch present yes nothing
awesome thank you guys
thanks for that room guys I really like
what
what
if you read this press the blue switch
I'm just gonna oh God that's terrifying
a vegetoid came out of the earth [ __ ]
that [ __ ]
blue one then it must be behind the
pillar
the switch press it yes
you're here clicking sound genius pill
strikes again that's right [ __ ]
okay now I'm here
uh if you can read this press the red
switch
oh God it looks
don't you just [ __ ] hate Luke's
Estonia
that's red isn't it
is that that straightforward okay I'll
take it thank you very much
how long is this gonna keep going I
don't know if you can read this press
the green switch is this the green one
no it was not I should have guessed that
the closest one was the Trap
but also I cannot be bothered
let me live my life the way I want to
live it
okay there we go let's do this again can
you run in this game or is this maximum
speed
I'm sure you can
[ __ ] it life's handing your lemons
so stick them up your your balls uh
that's disgusting I'm so sorry okay uh
flee
I want to heal it's a switch press it
yes
you sneaky Toby
you sneaky son of a snooper okay what do
we got
I'm not gonna walk on the leaves that
looks like a trap
okay that's beautiful
a toy knife
is that the view of the city
man I love the minimum minimalistic art
it's [ __ ] dope
oh man oh dear
that took longer than I thought it would
mom is she calling me from there
how did you get here my 10 are you hot
who did this to you
you will get an apology I should not
have left you alone for so long it was
irresponsible to try to surprise you
like this uh well I suppose I cannot
hide it any longer did she make us a pie
or something come small one
can't wait oh thank God I need this
save station Kalama
all right we're doing good breasts do
you smell that surprise it is
butterscotch cinnamon pie wow
thanks Mom you're the best
I thought we might celebrate your
arrival
I want you to have a nice time living
here
so I will hold off a snail pie for
tonight
thanks Mom
oh my phone sorry
uh here I have another surprise for you
this is it
a room of your own I hope you like it
oh is something Burning uh make yourself
a tone
okay I'm going to sleep
this is wonderful
you find a slice of butter Scotch
cinnamon pie
thanks Mom you're the best
toria's diary read the circle Passage
now I want to respect Toria she's my mom
after all
room under renovations
the hell does that mean
should we call Mom flirt
does that mean
I can flirt with Mom
oh hey
what the [ __ ]
I thought I would have flirt with myself
I don't know what I was expecting
honestly
let's find Mom
oh
Apple already I see
um I want you to know how glad I am to
have someone here there are so many old
books I want to share I want to show you
my favorite bug hunting spot I've also
prepared a curriculum for your education
this may come as a surprise to you but
I've always wanted to be a teacher
actually perhaps that isn't very
surprising still I am glad to have you
living here
oh did you want something what is it
when can I go home what this this is
your home now
um would you like to hear about this
book I'm reading it's called 72 uses for
snails I could actually use that I have
snails how about it
how to exit the runes sure
here's an exciting snail fact did you
know that snails talk really slowly just
kidding snails don't talk interesting
yeah
yes well bother me if you need anything
else and one more snail facts come on
[ __ ] is this there's some white fur
stuck in the drain
the pie
the size of the pie intimidates you too
much for you to eat it
stuff was very clean
I'm not sure
what I am supposed to do here we didn't
go downstairs did we let's go downstairs
this is creepy oh God Mom
I think she should play upstairs instead
damn
I feel like Edgar whenever he goes
somewhere I'll stop him all right well
then we're gonna read her [ __ ] diary
all right
because she's creeping me out
a bucket of snails what
Victoria okay
you read the passage why did the
skeleton want a friend but because she
was feeling bonely the rest of the pages
filled with jokes of a similar caliber
hilarious it's an oh God thanks Minx I
appreciate that it's an encyclopedia of
subterranean plants you open to the
middle
a group of wetland flowering plants with
brown oblong seed puds I could live
without that knowledge
known more commonly as water sausages
excellent
oh please not again
it's toriel's sock drawer scandalous
what happens if we sleep in her bed
definitely bigger than it oh
I'm not sure what I'm supposed to do
here
maybe we'll talk to toriel again
we can escape by
Escape her mother's love
she has to do something stay here
well we're not gonna stay here
she probably went downstairs don't you
think
oh
you wish how to
you wish to know how to return home
don't you not I never slides the end of
the ruins a one-way exit to the rest of
the underground I'm going to destroy it
no one will ever be able to live again
not a good child and go upstairs
nope
it's a very story based
I didn't think it would be the story
based every human that falls down here
meets the same fate I have seen it again
and again they come they leave they die
you naive Chan if you leave the ruins
they ask or will kill you I am only
protecting you do you not understand go
to your room
but Mom
bit men do not try to stop me this is
your final warning
I am a very disobedient child you want
to leave so badly hmm
you're just like the others there's only
one solution to this prove yourself
prove to me you are strong enough to
survive
are we gonna have to fight mom fight mom
[ __ ] yeah all right
is this our theme
uh I wonder what happens if I don't go
out ah [ __ ] it
oh God this is gonna be a while isn't it
I don't think I am strong enough
all right let's talk you couldn't think
of a conversation topics well I'm glad
we did that
foreign
what happens if I die
let's stay on purpose
you're not killing us on purpose
maybe I do have to actually oh yeah
uh maybe I do actually have to like
level up
like like they're all going away from me
I can't die
oh [ __ ] sorry oh I do a lot of damage
anyway
what is going on with this game there
it's so bizarre it's unlike anything I
ever played
like you never know what to expect
what's going on
okay well I I guess we're gonna just
wreck toriel
I like the music too
We're not gonna kill toriel though
we're not killing anyone don't worry all
right
oh
what what
you are stronger than I thought
listen to me small one
if you go beyond this door
keep walking as far as you can
eventually
you will reach and exit
triple Dutch quadruple Dodge
dude no I'm sorry let escort take
yourself
his plan cannot be allowed to succeed
six triplet Dot
child
my child oh
foreign
did I actually kill her
did I [ __ ] up that badly
okay well I [ __ ] that all right and
I'm sorry
I feel terrible
all right
I you saw obviously that I try not to
should we go back I'll go back because I
know people are just gonna be pissed
let's check oh man she's strong knows
best for you so if I keep hitting
despair
it seems like something's gonna happen
so let's try that attack or run away she
prepares a magical attack let's spare
her what are you proving this way
is that what she said I don't know if I
read that right
fight Me or Leave how long does this go
on
stop looking at me like that how long
does this go on
kill me
go away
Mom I'm not gonna hurt you Mom
triple that
I know you want to go home but
people die spare
but please go upstairs now
spare I promise I will take good care of
you here I kind of want to stay honestly
I know we do not have much but
we can have a good life here
why are you making this so difficult
go upstairs
haha
okay is it not I cannot save even a
single chat
it's such a weird secret no I understand
you would just be happy trapped down
here
the ruins are very small once you get
used to them it would not be right for
you to grow up in a place like this my
expectations my loneliness my fear for
you my child I will put them aside
if you truly wish to leave the ruins I
will not stop you however when you leave
please do not come back I hope you
understand oh
oh mom
goodbye my child
no
sorry owl
sounds like L'Oreal
oh she wanted to come back
um
all right let's go through
damn this is really cool
let's see what we can find she told us
keep walking
so I'm guessing this is going to be
quite a hallway
is it is it getting lighter brighter it
is isn't it yeah
see the light at the end of the tunnel
baby there it is
oh God it's you clever very clever you
think you're real smart don't you in
this world it's kill or be killed so you
were able to play by your own rules you
spared the life of a single person hey
don't act so cocky I Know What You Did
you murdered her and then you went back
because you regretted it
really
how did
don't break the fourth wall with me like
that I don't [ __ ] like that [ __ ]
[ __ ] you name idiot do you think you are
the only one with that power that is
[ __ ] creepy as [ __ ] [ __ ]
the power to reshape the world
purely by your own determination the
ability to play God the ability to save
I thought I was the only one with that
power but I can't save anymore
apparently your desires from this world
overrides mine well well enjoy that
power while you can I'll be watching
[ __ ] me that's creepy
I hate when games break the fourth wall
like that that's [ __ ] brilliant
the same with Napoleon [ __ ] all over
again Jesus Christ
oh God all right we're walking through
to the next ACT I suppose there we go
undertale okay well I I guess that's uh
by Toby Fox
uh I guess that's a good uh way to end
okay it keeps I'm trying to do an outro
here Toby
I guess we'll have to find
The Next Star
this is the new level oh this is creepy
very creepy is that a stick it's a tough
looking Branch it's too heavy to pick up
almost set
terrifying my God
uh
excuse me oh
death [ __ ] me
what is with these simple games there's
just so much
uh
let's keep oh God
who is this
don't you know how to create a new path
turn around and shake my hand
did he fart
that'll whoopee cushion in the hand
trick
you got me boy
it's always funny anyway you're human
right that's hilarious
I'm Sans Comic Sans the skeleton I'm
actually supposed to be on watch for
humans right now but you know I don't
really care I love how the eye is NOT
capitalized I don't really care about
capturing anybody not my brother papers
he is a human hunting fanatic hey
actually
is his brother the other font that is
like papers it's like the worst font you
could use that's that's clever hey
actually I think that's him over there I
have an idea go through this game thing
yeah go right through my bro made the
bars two white dude
stop
quick behind that conveniently shaped
lamp
it's this game
what's up bro
you know what you know what's up brother
it's been eight days and you still
haven't recalibrated your puzzles
you just hang around outside your
station what are you even doing
staring at this lamp it's really cool
you you want to look
no I don't have time for that
what if a human comes through here I
want to be ready I will be the one I
must be the one I will capture a human
then I the great Papyrus will get all
the utter the things I utterly deserve
respect recognition
I will finally be able to join the royal
guard people will ask to be my friend
I will bathe in the shower of kisses
everybody
it's like a great life
will help you
bones
all you do is sit and bondoggle Fandango
you get lazier laser every day hey hey
take it easy I gotten a ton of work done
today a skeleton
ah this game is so funny
come on you're smiling
I am and I hate it sorry
why does someone as great as me have to
do so much just to get some recognition
wow sounds like a really you're really
working yourself sorry I didn't read
that right down to the bone
ah I will and I will attend to my past
as for your work put a little more
backbone into it oh yeah
hey oh
okay you can come out now
oh I really I really have to go but I
gotta you ought to get get going you
might come but he might come back
sorry I need to calm down I can't mean
you'll have to sit through more of my
hilarious jokes
I can imagine Jack liking this character
that no one likes cheesy jokes more than
Jack what's the hold up look there's
nothing to be afraid of it's just a dark
Kevin filled with skeletons and horrible
monsters well you gotta get going you
might come back and if he does you'll
have to sit through more hilarious dudes
okay
I want to say there's some sort of
checkpoint or Central Station but
they're a bottle of ketchup mustard and
relish okay actually hey
to bother you but can you do me a favor
I was thinking my brother's been kind of
down lately it's never seen a human
before I'm saying you might just make a
steak don't worry he's not dangerous
it drives to be thanks a million I'll be
up ahead foreign
I'll do a save here finally and uh we'll
end part one here thank you so much for
watching really really enjoy this it
makes me almost like why didn't I play
this sooner
um I can tell it's gonna be a great
playthrough go ahead and check out part
two it's up right now like I said the
whole thing is up right now uh watch it
at your own pace whatever you do and uh
thank you for leaving a like I really
appreciate it it especially the First
videos it's good if you do it and that's
it for me for now thank you both for
watching I'll see you in the next one